today i want to talk a little bit about
a super interesting innovative
cryptocurrency platform i've been
following called trust swap we've
partnered with trust swap
on this video when we talk about the
traditional finance world
venture capital firms get early access
to startups to the new businesses with
an idea looking for investors to get off
the ground
and because venture capital has this
exclusivity the general public
is often excluded from buying into a
startup early when the shares are cheap
and there's potentially
huge opportunity the trust swap platform
aims to give venture capital power
to everyone by giving users priority
and early stage access to crypto and
blockchain startups
trust swaps native token is called swap
and by taking swap you are guaranteed
access
to investing in these startups
the more swap you stake the larger
allocation you get
trust swap allows the general public
early access to startups
through their feature called launch pads
which i think is the most interesting
piece of the trust swap ecosystem and
the launch pads
are a huge phenomenon in crypto right
now trust swap is ranked as one of
the top launch pads in the industry by
coin gecko
and trust swap says that their launch
pad
is the only one in the crypto space with
a guaranteed allocation
with an average return of 10 to 20 x now
i'm going to show you some of the launch
pads that are available right now
we have verso a project fully incubated
by trust swap a few others
more defy kel vpn is an interesting
decentralized vpn
i was checking out stator is an open
source peer-to-peer lending platform
for nfts non-fungible tokens so there's
a big variety
of different types of projects you can
get involved with
another feature of trust swap is the
platform
uh is uh smart lock the feature smart
lock
smart lock is a decentralized app that
lets crypto projects
lock their erc 20 coins on liquidity
pool tokens in a non-custodial
time release smart contract vault every
day
there are multi-million dollar crypto
projects popping up
a crucial part of making the space work
is keeping
digital assets safe both for the project
teams and for their communities and
smart lock
is the trust swap feature to make that
happen you
input your liquidity tokens into a time
released
vault that returns the tokens at a
specified date
and team token investing lets you create
a schedule for team members with
specific dates and token amounts
and your public facing smart lock
profile lets you display your lock
tokens and the vesting schedules on the
internet
another innovative component of trust
swap is
smart mint it lets you create your own
audited crypto in minutes doesn't
require you to do any coding at all
at this point really anyone can create a
cryptocurrency and launch it on uniswap
and i think this access to markets the
ease with which people can innovate
has been a really big net positive for
blockchain and for defy
but it doesn't come without some serious
risks the biggest of which could be
that there are scams in the crypto space
so it can seem almost impossible to
mitigate all of these different
attack vectors trust swap solution
is smartmint which comes with a mint
token generator
letting you create a fully audited token
without any fee
any token generated can seamlessly take
a portion of the tokens
lock them in a vesting schedule and it
gives confidence to the token holders
because it's been pre-audited and you
can add features to your tokens like
minting burning and staking
another aspect of the trust swap
platform is called swappable
which is really the first nft and drc 20
marketplace that gives returns back to
its own community which is
very interesting and it allows anyone
with a web3 wallet to create buy
sell or trade nfts and make trustless
peer-to-peer swaps
of any erc token so trust swap
as a platform is already a fully
realized set of services
and these are services that bring really
cool and unique solutions to real
problems
and there's a ton of demand for what
they're providing people creating their
own cryptos
and nfts people looking to get early
access to investing in other cryptos
and i think trust swap provides some
easy and reliable means of doing those
things
i really think that the launchpad's
function of trust swap
is the most interesting to me it's just
a simple
powerful sort of elegant way to get in
on the ground floor
on project token sales so i would
encourage you to check out trust swap
learn how it works very easy to use you
can go to trustswap.org
there's a link right underneath the
video and as always
this is my analysis of the project
always do your own research anytime
you're looking at a financial investment
of any kind